[Music]
when it comes to unlocking all the
benefits of the cloud
you don't want identity and access
management to get in the way
users from your company can use their
existing accounts to access your
company's google cloud environment by
signing in with their credentials
and you can manage which permissions
these users have with identity and
access management
or iam for short
but when users who use a different
identity provider need access things
aren't so simple
using an external identity provider can
make getting access complicated and get
in the way of doing the work that really
matters
so how can you provide your employees
partners contractors and everyone else
with a secure way to access your
environment and resources
workforce identity federation lets you
use an external identity provider to
directly authenticate users into your
google cloud environment
now you have even more control for how
users can sign into and access google
cloud services
with workforce identity federation
you don't need to synchronize user
identities from your existing identity
provider into google cloud
instead
users will be able to authenticate with
their existing credentials in a single
sign-on flow let's take a closer look at
how it works
first the user can sign in through a
typical login flow this can include the
interface offered by your identity
provider the interface from your service
provider such as google cloud or by
using the apis or command line interface
all of these will use your identity
provider's information to authenticate
the user and will return a response
validating the user
then
the valid response is sent to workforce
identity federation where the token is
validated against the rules that you've
set up
a new google cloud token will be
generated that contains the
authorization for this user
finally the user can be redirected to
the console using the new login token
now you've ensured that only legitimate
users have access to authorized
resources with a frictionless sign-on
experience and you don't need to manage
syncing up identities between providers
in order for a user to sign in with
workforce identity federation
you'll first need to set it up for your
google cloud organization
this setup process involves two steps
first
you'll need to set up one or more
workforce pools
these pools let you manage and group
together users
and control their access to your google
cloud environment
you can customize the identity and
access management permissions for each
pool
so you can follow the best practice of
least privilege and ensure that users
only have the permissions they need
in addition to setting im permissions
for an entire pool
you can also set permissions for
individual users or subgroups of a pool
based on attributes from your identity
provider
once you've created your workforce pools
you'll need to create a workforce
identity pool provider for each pool
these pool providers store the
information for your identity provider
as well as the mapping for attributes
you can also customize how attributes
are mapped from your identity provider
so you only need to include the
necessary details and protect your users
data
pools can be mapped to a group of users
using these attributes such as
separating employees from partners
with the workforce pool and workforce
pool provider setup users can seamlessly
sign in and access your google cloud
resources
to learn more about how workforce
identity federation can help you manage
access to your google cloud environment
check out the documentation and try it
out for yourself